[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
Welcome, everyone.
Thanks for coming to
our session, where
we're going to talk about
the future of meetings.
My name is Serge Lachapelle.
I'm a product manager, working
on enterprise collaboration.
And this is my colleague.
PATRICK WYNN: Patrick Winn,
also a product manager
on Hangouts, and specifically
for video meetings.
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
And so, today I
want to reinforce some
of the messages you heard
this morning at the keynote.
We're all in on
enterprise communication.
And whether it is textural
team communication over chat,
team communication over
video, and extending
into interactions, such as
with the white board or the jam
board.
And so, today, this session
will go do a deep dive
on the Hangouts Meet experience
that we presented this morning.
And I'm going to talk about an
epidemic throughout this talk.
And it's a silent
epidemic in the workplace.
More specifically, I'm
talking about the fact
that 16.7% percent of every
work day is getting wasted.
My day is full of 30-minute
meetings, and many of them
are online meetings.
And imagine losing
five minutes to set up
for every one of those meetings.
That's 16.7% percent
of your allocated time.
So, of course I use this
number figuratively, but still
an incredible number.
Even if it was 5%.
Imagine being able to give
your workforce and all
of your teams 5%
of their time back.
And here's how we waste time.
We waste time figuring
how to get things to work.
You have to download software
for many online meeting
experiences.
You might not have the
administrative privileges
to install software.
Your IT department might
be white listing software.
So you have to go file
a ticket, get permission
to install piece of software
X to get into a meeting.
Of course, the usual struggles
with the audio and video
issues of trying to understand
which microphone you're using,
the cameras you're using.
And then, one that
we often forget
is that, "Oh I'm using
system X, so I'll
need a system X account".
And then I'll have to
go create an account,
I have to remember the
password, I have to log in.
All of these things cost us
time and make us less efficient.
I work with global teams.
I'm based out of
Stockholm, in Sweden.
Patrick is based
in the Bay Area.
Many of my colleagues
here, in front with me,
work out of our Kirkland, right
outside of Seattle office.
And we work very
closely together.
So, we need tools that
can support our reality
of global engineering.
We're all on the
move, we all try
to balance life,
family life, and work.
Being able to take
meetings from outside
of the office, where on the
go, is an important part
of our workflow.
And more and more,
the company intranet
doesn't mean anything anymore.
We source out some
engineering, we source
out some testing,
some marketing,
you work with legal people
from other companies.
And so, this domain focus
on communication tools
needs to be broken up because
it doesn't match the workflows
that we have today.
So I did some napkin math.
In my talk, yesterday,
I shared a little bit
about the meeting numbers
at Google internally.
We've got somewhere close
to 70,000 employees.
These employees dial in to
video meetings 230,000 times
every day.
They dial in across their
laptops, their phones,
or the meeting rooms.
And we spend about
nine years, actually
9.2, 9.3 years of time every
day in a video meeting.
So, if we were to incur a
loss of a loss of five minutes
for every one of those meetings,
due to trying to set up
or trying to get
things going, that's
over $200,000 in lost
productivity every day.
I'd like to find
a CIO that would
be willing to sign a purchase
order for $200,000 every day
because of lost productivity.
So, this is a fun number.
But, really, what
it's all about is
about removing the interruptions
that can create frustration.
These break the flow.
They hurt our ability
to do good teamwork,
and they harm these
moments of connection
that you create
with your teams that
are spread all over the world.
And, while we can look
at Google's use case,
you've all been
incredible at giving us
feedback on the solutions
that we had in the enterprise.
And what's staggering
is that Patrick and I,
we've talked to many of you that
use video meetings more than
what Google does.
And you use video
meetings in ways
that are very different
to what Google does.
And we've learned
a lot from these.
If we were to
categorize the feedback,
we'd put them under
several pillars,
and I'll walk through
these pillars now.
Things are too hard to access.
Hard to get into a meeting, hard
to invite people, especially
customers, people that are
external to your domain.
I often use the example,
I want General Motors
to be able to talk to Ford,
as a hypothetical example.
And this should work.
You can expect Ford employees
to have General Motor
addresses, or vice versa.
And when things fail,
you want a backup.
Maybe you're on the road,
maybe you're driving.
The ability to
dial into a meeting
was also a key piece of
feedback that we've received.
And access is also
about not missing out
if you can't be there,
if you're not available.
And recording was a key
piece of feedback in these.
These systems are hard to use.
There's a lot of buttons,
there's a lot of knobs.
It breaks confidence.
Simple actions just as
presenting feel contrived them
and, again, you lose this
feeling of confidence
when you're talking
to your audience.
Another piece of
feedback we've gotten
is that a lot of the
systems out there.
The user experience
is different,
whether in your conference
room, on your laptop,
or on your phone.
And so, trying to
add consistency
across all the devices
one supports is important.
We've heard a lot about
performance issues,
audio issues, video issues.
User experiences
that aren't snappy,
aren't responsive enough.
Bandwidth requirements
that are too high,
deployments that don't work
across corporate networks,
that are firewalled, that
have enterprise requirements.
And so, of course, we took a
deep look at our own usage.
But the fantastic thing
was all this feedback
that we've been able
to receive from you
and build into a great product.
And so, that's why today, we're
introducing Hangouts Meet.
We feel that this is
a videoconferencing
experience that will give
you 16.7% of your day back.
And it just works.
So, we're going to do
a demo, and Patrick
is going to help out.
A little bit similar to the
demo that was done this morning,
but we're going to go much
more in-depth into it.
So, let's switch to
the laptop, please.
And so, this is Google Calendar.
And the Cloudy Coffee Company
has been invited to a meeting.
And, just as normal
with a calendar invite,
you can open it and follow
the link to the meeting.
So, from Google
Calendar, from an email,
from your favorite messaging
app, that link can be opened.
This is a Chrome
browser, no plug-in,
no software was downloaded
to get to this experience.
And everything I'm
going to demo today,
no download, no software.
Native to the browser.
This is a green room.
This is where we
can check our hair,
this is where we
can mute ourselves.
It's to make sure
as well that I don't
join a meeting by accident,
that I join when I'm ready.
But, more importantly, if I'm
in a Google-powered conference
room, I might want to not
join the full meeting.
Maybe I'm in this room just
to present to the meeting
because I have the video
conference already running
in front of me.
And, you know, I took this out
of my little travel bag today.
These are all the
adapters I travel with.
HDMI to us USB C, DVI to
display port, VGA, of course,
because, you know,
you can't go anywhere
without 1980s technology.
And this is VGA to USB
C. I mean, this is like--
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know about you,
but this feels wrong.
So, if I want to just
present, I present.
I choose what I want to present,
and it shows up on the TV
and to my audience online.
But now, we're going to
go in the meeting full-in.
And before we do that,
this is an i5 Chromebook
from early last year, and
we're just running Chrome.
And I want you to take
attention to how quickly I
get into the meeting from here.
Boom.
So, this is about 80, 90% faster
than the classic Hangouts.
[APPALUSE]
Thank you.
And if we're allowed to
geek out a little bit,
we've rebuilt the
whole JavaScript,
it uses half the RAM of the
classic Hangouts experience.
This experience renders
much, much more video frames
per second than the
previous experience.
And it also reaches HD
quality much faster,
whereas the classic Hangout
could take up to 10 seconds
to reach HD quality to ramp up,
to not overload the network.
This one can do it
well under a second.
In fact, we're seeing average
times of 100, 200 milliseconds
to reach HD quality.
So, online with me, we have our
product managers in Kirkland.
Hi, Erika.
ERIKA: Hi.
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
And we have Boyana,
who is sitting in a Chromebox
for Meeting-powered meeting
room in our Seattle office.
BOYANA: Hello.
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
Hi, and hi to both.
So, I'll walk you through
the UI of this experience.
So we've worked hard at
making things simple,
getting things out of the
way of your conversation.
One of the first
things we've learned
is that when we do
document sharing,
they are often taller
than they are wide.
So we've moved the
thumbnails to the side.
We've also made the
commands to control
the meeting very simple.
So, by just moving your mouse,
you see, I can mute myself,
I can hang up, I
can mute the camera,
and most importantly,
I can easily present.
And we've worked
with the Chrome team
to redo the whole
presentation UI flow.
So that now, you will
have an experience
that puts you much
more in control of what
you're selecting to present.
Whether it's a Chrome tab, a
window, or your whole desktop.
Thanks, Patrick.
And, finally, this is a meeting.
I might want to invite
other people that
were not on the calendar
to this meeting.
So, I can easily pull up
the meeting information,
copy this to my clipboard,
and share it out.
And I think this is what
we're going to do now.
So, we're going to pretend
that we're virtually something
that email out.
And now, we have
someone knocking in.
Katie works out the
Cloudy Coffee Company,
she's outside of Hooli.
She doesn't have
a Gmail address.
She has never heard of Google,
she's never heard of Google.
But she can still come
in without any accounts.
So, let's admit Katie
into our meeting.
And Katie is somewhere
here sitting.
Ah, Can you say hi?
So, she just joined on the
iOS client for Hangouts meet.
And this was also a problem.
Individuals that are sometimes
doing freelancing or going
to an interview, they don't want
to share their private Gmail
address.
I remember talking with Chris
about this a while back.
We've seen people with
Gmail addresses such as,
IHateBabySeal78@Gmail.com.
And you don't want to
show that to an employer,
you don't want to show
that in a meeting context,
and you don't want to force
people to go create new Gmail
addresses just so that they
won't show up in a meeting.
So, being able to be
completely accountless
and going into a meeting is a
core part of this experience.
Let's talk more about
mobile, shall we?
PATRICK WYNN: Sure.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: I'll
let you take that part
while I drink a little water.
PATRICK WYNN: OK.
Yes.
So we have mobile clients
for Android and iOS.
And they are purpose-built for
this enterprise experience,
as Serge mentioned.
So, if we switch to Vision.
So, this is just the
standard Google Pixel.
And what you'll see here is
that we have an app that's
designed for this experience,
like you said earlier,
it has that context built in.
I don't know if you
noticed we pulled
the information from Calendar.
So, if someone has bothered
to put all that prep
information in the
Calendar, we surface
that within the meeting.
And it's no exception here.
So, I can click on
this meeting here
and you can see all
the meeting details,
you can see who's
invited and so on.
So, it's all
integrated that way.
And I can also join the meeting.
So, if I click back
on join, there.
And it was also
linked there earlier.
So, we're going to
mute here for a second,
so we don't get any feedback.
But this is what the
experience is like for someone.
So, this is what
Katie sees, basically,
right now on her iOS device.
And again, you see
all the same details,
it's just there to
keep you in context,
so you can catch
meetings on the fly.
You don't have to
read your crib notes
and then switch
back to the meeting.
So, that's all fun.
I'm going to quit
the meeting for now.
The other thing we realized was
that the reality is that you're
running on the go to airports.
I'm sure some of you flew
through airports, or landed
and took off from them,
at least, to get here.
And when you're on the
go, especially when
you're roaming or something
like that, the reality--
I know it's 2017, but you
just don't have access
to the internet on your phone.
So, you still need to
get into your meetings,
and we understand that.
So, with every meeting we
have on the enterprise--
sorry, if you get
Enterprise G Suite,
every meeting will give you
a dial in number and PIN.
And that's unique
to that meeting,
so you don't have to worry
about deploying numbers or host
PINS and all that
stuff, it just works.
You just create your
meeting and you get it.
So, if I join this call here.
This is just an
ordinary phone call.
You can see one
click to connect,
one to send the meeting code.
And I'm going to mute again.
And that just
connects me through,
so I don't have to
type in the PIN,
and it'll just help me join
the meeting a lot quicker.
So, you'll see once
that's entered,
then I'll join the meeting
and you're on the way.
Now, the other thing
to show is that--
I'm going to quit
that for a second.
We've integrated that directly
into Google Calendar as well.
So, if I jump back
into the calendar here,
you can see here's the original
Calendar event you saw earlier.
All those details are also
in the Calendar event invite.
So, if I click the phone
number there again,
you get the same
click-to-join experience.
So, generally, it's
about two clicks
and you're into the call.
Doesn't matter whether
you're on iOS or Android.
And that's that.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Thank you.
And that's an important
thing to remember.
Every meeting you
create with this system,
if you're an Enterprise
G Suite user,
you will get a phone number
and PIN attached to it
automatically.
It's fire and forget.
That's the default
part of the experience.
I learned that not roam--
I roamed too much
internationally last week
and I lost data access because
I had to confirm to my carrier
that, yes, I had
spent up all my data.
And then, I wasn't able to
join a meeting, boop, click,
switched to the mobile phone.
So, thank you, Patrick.
PATRICK WYNN: Do you want
to switch back the slides?
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Let's
switch back to the slides.
Thank you.
We've been testing
this since September
at over 300 companies
that are G Suite users.
We've had 15,000
end-user accounts
creating Hangouts
meetings since then.
And the feedback has been
really positive, so, thank you
to all of us who are part
of our early access program.
With our UX research group
we've done a lot of interviews,
we've done a lot of surveys,
and we can confidently
say that this user group has
felt that audio and video
quality, their satisfaction
with audio and video quality
has more than doubled.
And I think that was an
amazing moment for us
to get those results in.
So, we're talking about
an enterprise context,
we're talking about a shift of
video conferencing experience
into the enterprise.
And it's very important
for us to show,
not only that we're
not stopping here,
we've got a team of people
working on amazing features
coming up over the
next few months.
I can see some of my engineering
colleagues here a bit nervous,
and want me to spill the beans,
but I will spill some beans.
So, here's what
we're working on,
and here's what we expect
to be able to either have
in your hands as testers,
or as a full-blown feature
before the summer.
Summer in Sweden comes a little
bit later, so just so you know.
[LAUGHS]
Internally at Google, we've
turned this on a few weeks ago.
You can save meetings
to Google Drive,
and you can share them as
a video file afterwards.
And we feel that this is
going to be super impactful,
and we'll be releasing this
over the next couple of months.
And we're really excited
about this feature.
For certain
enterprise customers,
this is not possible, this
should not be allowed,
so, of course, you will
have the levers inside
of your administrator
panel to turn this on
or off at your desire.
Hangouts Meet today
supports 30 fully
participative participants.
I shouldn't have written
that, it was a tongue twister.
And this is important.
This isn't a system where
I pass a speaker baton
and say, "It's your turn,
now it's your turn to talk".
This is a system that works for
teams, where everyone can talk,
where everyone can interact.
And so, building
a system like that
means a much higher load
on the infrastructure
and on the clients.
But we're happy to announce
that, again, before the summer,
we will be supporting larger
meeting rooms of up to 50 fully
participative participants.
Thank you.
Everything that
you've seen doesn't
require any server, any
infrastructure locally,
it's all Cloud-powered.
But, as an enterprise,
you are also
conscious of bandwidth
costs, and so are we.
So, we've been working
hard at upgrading our Cloud
infrastructure to reduce the
requirements on bandwidth
for powering these meetings.
And so, there's no
on-premise software,
no on-premise hardware.
Everything is
powered by our Cloud,
and the requirements for
driving beautiful meetings
from Hangouts Meet
are going to go down
over the next few
months, as well.
As we've improved a lot
of our infrastructure.
And we've also worked
closely with the Chrome team.
As an administrator, you
can now push a Chrome policy
that tells the browser to
use this range of UDP ports
because your corporate firewall
and your internal security
responsibles might have these
policies already in place.
So, as an administrator, you
can tell all of your browsers
to go to this set of ports.
And that means that
connections will probably
happen a lot more direct.
And, in the past, if
ports were blocked
or the right port
range wasn't used,
Hangouts might try to
default and tunnel itself
over web traffic.
And we all know
web traffic is very
different to real-time
traffic requirements of audio
and video.
So, this is to help improve
your connection rates
and also help improve the
performance and the quality
that you see.
We're also going to be
releasing, as part of Chrome,
support for authenticated
web proxies.
And, yes, this also
feels like VGA,
but there are many, many,
many companies today
where all the browsers,
all the internet access,
is done through web
proxies still today.
And, so having support
for that means that you'll
be able to talk to your banker.
I've worked at
Google for 10 years.
I've never received feedback
like this for a product.
And these are
customers on our EAP,
I have grayed out the names
and email addresses, that
went through the bug
filing tool to tell us
that they loved the experience.
That has never happened.
So, for me, that
was a moment when
we sat together with the team
and said, "Yes, we should
go for it and launch it".
So, thank you to all that
have submitted this feedback.
It's been an amazing source
of motivation for us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So, we're going to continue
to work really, really
hard at polishing, polishing,
polishing, removing friction
everywhere we see it.
And our model is,
really, to give you
16.7% of your online
meeting work day back,
so that you have time for these
kinds of Hangouts, instead.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]